let's take some phone calls at (617) 830-4750
a lot of folks wanting to talk about many
things, including presumably at least some,
uh, the news of the day.
Let's start today with our caller from the
three zero one area code.
Who's calling today from three zero one
I gave it this, a little bell up in Pittsburgh.
How are you?
Good.
Okay.
Doing very good and good.
Um, I just wanted to ask you about, there's
a new batch of polls that were released to
gauge, do you see the, the Quinnipiac and
the UCO?
So I don't remember which pulse said what,
but I know that over the last couple of days
there's one poll which has Elizabeth Warren
ahead nationally.
I'm wondering if that's one of the ones you're
referring to.
There's another pole which has, uh, Andrew
Yang pulling 8%.
I think that's the Emerson poll.
So yes, I've generally been keeping up with
them.
Gotcha.
Yeah, like the, um, the Quinnipiac and one
at 27, bottom 25.
And the YouGov, it was among the lucky voters.
It was putting five for both biding Warren.
Um, and I mostly highlighting, get to see
the breakdown for you go.
But for the Quinnipiac poll, I saw it with
born in July of this year, she had 4% of the
black votes, uh, by I'm 53 and then now it
says she has 19% of the black vote by 40.
And yes, basically I didn't make my eyes pop
up because especially for me, because I'm
a black millennial and I would want more intimate
and I don't want up against the white house.
Um, so, um, I just had just a couple questions,
but that, do you, um, do you see, is there
like a four that you think warm Walden need
to comfortably win the nomination or like
among blacks of court and just assuming that
as a hypothetical vet, she, um, didn't catch
up with byte in terms of the black vote.
I'm also costume, but she won a majority of
the early States such as Iowa, New Hampshire,
Nevada.
Could you see a Obama Hillary type situation
where the box support swings away
isn't, I'd have to look more in deeply at
the numbers.
I think that Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders,
Liz, I think any of these candidates could
win the nomination without a majority of the
black vote, if that's what you're asking.
I don't think they need a majority of the
black vote necessarily.
Um, but I think certainly we want to be paying
attention to, are there certain groups with
which a particular candidate is or is not
doing well and what would the reasons for
that be?
But I'd have to, I don't know what the floor
would be of like, I wouldn't be prepared to
say if Elizabeth Warren doesn't get X percent
of the black vote, she can't win the nomination,
that number probably exists.
I just don't know what it would be.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Yeah, like that definitely makes sense.
Especially since I didn't feel like I could
seem to have answered, but I just, because
again, it was just released, you know?
Yes.
We will be looking at it in significant detail
and I appreciate you bringing it up.
Lavelle from Pittsburgh.
Great to hear from you today.
I do appreciate the phone call.